detrás de mí el hospital Militar en el
norte de Bogotá donde están siendo
tratados los cuatro niños colombianos
encontrados en el día de ayer tras más
de 40 días perdidos en la selva y tras
sobrevivir a un accidente de avioneta en
el que murió su madre y otros dos
adultos fuentes de la operación de
rescate nos comentan que los niños
estarían bien estarían un poco
deshidratados y que la niña mayor
tendría un golpe leve en la cabeza este
operativo ha sido tenido como lema
buscarlos hasta encontrarlos hasta o
liderado por las fuerzas armadas en
conjunto con grupos indígenas en una
unión inédita para Colombia y al final
ha tenido un final feliz fuentes de
operación también nos han comentado que
las técnicas que se han usado resultaron
ser exitosas ya que entre otras lanzaron
flyers desde el helicóptero pero también
paquetes de comida que habrían
encontrado los niños como habría
confesado como habría confirmado la niña
mayor y los han podido comer y
alimentarse en estos días también
habrían escuchado los niños los mensajes
de audio grabados con voz de su abuela
en lengua indígena llamándolos a que
apareciesen pero sabrían asustado Y se
habrían escondido de estos mensajes un
final feliz después de que en el día de
ayer a las 5 de la tarde un grupo de
indígenas murui encontrase a los niños
los entregase después a las fuerzas
especiales que los sacarían de la selva
San José del guaviare una de las
principales ciudades de la selva y
finalmente a medianoche llegaron a
Bogotá para ser atendidos en este
hospital Militar en un viernes que fue
calificado del presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro de mágico